cher monsieur le président chers
emmanuel mesdames et messieurs 1 chères
invitées et chers journalistes
je suis ravi de celui en ukraine le
président de la république française
emmanuel macron cela fait vingt quatre
ans que nous à la groupe a reçu deux
leaders français et nous sommes honorés
de ta visite note avions attendu une
première sion pour ton soutien personnel
un vis-à-vis de l'ukraine et les vrais
un coup nos pays développent des
relations de coopération dans tous les
domaines mais je voudrais souligner et
le domaine de sécurité
la france joue un rôle très actif dans
le cadre du format de normandie et un
nous en apprécions beaucoup la position
de paris et des menus et le maquereau un
personnellement pour atteindre la paix
en ukraine et c'est un vrai que c'est
une question primordiale pour un an pour
parler aujourd'hui nous espérons que
d'enlever l'avenir très proche nous
allons pouvoir atteindre à tout ce qui
était prévu en décembre 2019 et avoir un
nouveau sommet des leaders du format de
normandie
normalisé à les négociations nous avons
eu une rencontre entre les conseillers
politiques
infructueuses et non nous attendons à ce
que 1 ces rencontres la rencontre le 26
janvier ou 2022 et les pourparlers à
berlin pour nous rapprocher du sommet
qu'il forma de normandie nous avons la
vision commune avec le président macro à
des menaces actuelles fin et menaces
pour la sécurité et pauvres le cren pour
le monde en général
il faut de l'unité 1 2-1 tous les
participants et la d occupation d'une
partie de notre territoire est très
important antonia le soutien de la part
des partenaires pour augmenter la
capacité de défense de l'ukraine est
très important pour toute la région et
de la part de tous les pays de l'union
européenne et le soutien pour la
sécurité et le soutien économique sont
très importants et nous en apprécions
beaucoup hein ce pas un très important
de la part de l'occident et de la part
des manuels et de la france 1,2 milliard
d'euros un dead macro financière est
accordée pour le cren cela permettra de
stabiliser notre économie est un c'est
un pas très puissant pourra assurer la
stabilité la résilience économique de
l'ukraine il est important que la france
participe aux grands projets notamment
d'infrastructures en ukraine et
j'apprécie le fait que la france
participe activement pour renouveler
l'infrastructure de notre pays pour
améliorer la qualité de vie de nos
citoyens et en premier lieu à l'est de
l'ukraine et nous mettons en oeuvre
ensemble
1 un projet très important pour
les pins cela le nettoyage de l'eau et
à l'accès à l'eau potable de bonne
qualité
à dans la région de lougansk hommes ce
qui est très important un cours un
million de nos citoyens qui habitent
dans cette région de lougansk nous avoue
notamment des projets très importants
faut venir 101 30 locomotives d'alstom
pour 900 millions d'euros et 3 101 70
unités attendues de véhicules de
pompiers pour 300 millions d'euros
nicolas lièvre mikolaj et un il y a des
patrouilleurs 1 pour les
gardes-frontières qui sont en
construction et la compagnie air basse
un travail pour créer ensemble un
transporteur aérien commun et nous avons
signé aujourd'hui un accord de
coopération entre hook robben prom et à
la partie française l'entreprise thalès
une déclaration commune entre ou creux
oboronprom et thales a été signé
aujourd'hui pour la modernisation de
l'ensemble des incapacités en ukraine je
remercie pour ces pourparlers je
remercie personnellement un manuel
m'accroche je remercie la france
insupportable et et ses initiatives
pourront favoriser né à des sujets très
important et le plus un don important
c'est le la sécurité de notre pays et de
l'europe et je te remercie d'être venu
de me soutenir moi de soutenir l'état
ukrainien est donc de se tenir chaque
citoyen craignant
déclarations du président de la
république française emmanuel macron
monsieur le président cela veut dire
pour
l'accueil aujourd'hui à kiev dans ce
moment de grande tension autour de votre
pays et merci pour vos mots à l'instant
depuis la révolution de maidan en 2013
l'ukraine a choisi la voie des réformes
et de la démocratie et ce choix a été
fait par le peuple ukrainien qui s'est
mobilisé pour cet objectif et vous le
savez les européens accompagne vos
efforts de transformation qui sont aussi
une garantie de votre souveraineté
vous pouvez à cet égard on le savait
compter sur notre soutien
depuis huit ans le cren s'est déjà
considérablement transformé
il se marre
résolument en avant par les l'un et
l'autre chemin sur lequel il n'y a pas
de marche en arrière
je veux ici rendre hommage aux
manifestants du maiden et au 1008 de
soldats morts sur le front depuis 2014
pour défendre leur patrie
il se battait pour l'ukraine
et je veux ici éviter toute forme de
simplification parfois imposées de
l'étranger parfois des fins de
déstabilisation
monsieur le président chers volodymyr se
voulait dit tout à l'heure comme je les
dis hier publiquement à moscou dans le
contexte que nous connaissons
le sang froid dont vous faites preuve et
dont fait preuve le peuple ukrainien
face à la pression militaire qui
s'exerce à vos frontières et sur votre
territoire force le respect
aux côtés de l'allemagne la france s'est
déterminé mais si le président va suivre
un assemblement ses efforts de médiation
entre la russie et l'ukraine pour mettre
fin
au conflit
nous avons eu l'occasion ensemble avec
le président poutine et les pauvres et
sans salir merkel de tenir ce qui fut le
dernier
dernière réunion en forme a dit de
normandie à paris en décembre 2019 donc
les quatre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du format normande et des
parvenus à se mettre d'accord sur des
mesures immédiates à mettre en oeuvre
en particulier dans le domaine
humanitaire
le 26 janvier dernier les quatre pays
ont réaffirmé leur engagement à mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk qui ont
vocation à rendre à l'ukraine son
intégrité territoriale
et qui trace le chemin vers la paix
hier avec le président poutine j'ai
longuement évoqué évidemment ce sujet et
il s'est lui-même ré engagé à respecter
les accords de risques
et je veux ici vous remercier de m'avoir
confirmé à l'instant lors de nos
échanges de manière très claire votre
volonté de mettre en oeuvre ces mêmes
accords
c'est cette détermination partagée qui
est le seul chemin nous permettant de
construire la paix
le seul chemin permettant de construire
une solution politique viable
je veux ici rappeler que
la base de l'accord de minsk 2 février
2015 son objectif est entre autres le
retour des territoires séparatistes de
n'être que de loin sous la souveraineté
de l'ukraine et qu'à cet égard les
accords de minsk sont aussi la meilleure
protection de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine
sur la base de ce double engagement
russes et ukrainiens
nous avons désormais la possibilité de
faire avancer ces négociations
beaucoup de temps a été perdu à
s'interroger sur tel ou tel format sur
telle ou telle méthode de négociation je
crois qu'il est désormais temps que tous
les participants à cette négociation
s'engage dans un dialogue de bonne foi
le chemin est possible de notre volonté
pour ce qui est belle manière de la
france est de vous accompagner sur celui
ci
et je souhaite donc que nous allons
continuer de l'évoquer ensemble à
nouveau en rentrant dans le détail mais
que nous puissions de manière très
concrète
avancées sur les sujets techniques qui
restent grâce à votre détermination
m'avait également confirmé votre
attachement au cessez le feu et une
réunion des conseillers du format
normandie aura lieu ce jeudi à berlin je
souhaite qu'elle parvienne à l'avancé
justement à la fois sur la mise en
oeuvre des mesures politiques et
humanitaires
ce processus de règlement
doit précisément avancé indépendamment
des tensions sur notre continent
et de la pression militaire avant
frontières
mettrait clairement en plus de ce
processus il ya aujourd'hui
une pression militaire et nelly d'exil
des exercices militaires nouveau et un
risque d'escaladé
la russie en adoptant cette posture
menaçante a décidé très clairement de
mettre pression sur la communauté
internationale
j'ai eu l'occasion hier en parler
longuement avec le président poutine il
a des marges que j'ai engagées en ne
rendant à moscou et à kiev vise
précisément à
restituer collectivement or
stabilité et sécurité sur notre
continent est mise à mal par cette
pression militaire croissante
je crois pour ma part qu'il y a des
solutions concrètes
pratiques qui nous permettront d'avancer
nous avons eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
ensemble j'ai eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
également avec le président poutine
comme je lé fais avec mes partenaires
européens et plusieurs de nos amis
notre volonté pour les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois
et justement que la situation se
stabilise et une qu'une opposition
réengagé
par des mécanismes de garantie nouveau
une désescalade plus rares
dans ce contexte le calme dans cette
preuve la pondération
de toutes les parties prenantes dans les
propos comme dans les agressions
indispensable
vous l'avez compris
le devoir qui est le nôtre pour les
jours et les semaines à venir et
d'avancer sur ce double chemin le
premier la mise en oeuvre
résolue méthodique des accords de minsk
dans le cadre du format dans le deuxième
le dialogue la exigeant innovant qui
permettra de construire des garanties
communes nouvelles et de bâtir la
sécurité et la stabilité sur notre
continent et de le faire en préservant
la sécurité de courtage
enfin le soutien de la france à
l'ukraine passe aussi par le
renforcement constant depuis plusieurs
années de nos relations vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le président nos
relations économiques et financières
dans des domaines multiples que comme la
sécurité civile comme le sanitaire les
domaines comme les infrastructures ou
les équipements je viens aussi à kiev
dans ce climat régional que j'évoquais
de grande tension pour marquer la
confiance que nous avons dans la
résilience de l'ukraine et son économie
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de
mobiliser
près de 1,2 milliard d'euros sous la
forme de garanties pour financer des
projets supplémentaires
plusieurs ont été signés ou seront
signés ce matin et de montrer ainsi
notre confiance dans notre économie
dans les projets qui est un gage de la
stabilité
de tout le pays
je terminerai en redisant le respect de
la france pour
les aspirations du peuple ukrainien
et la disponibilité de la france à
consolider la souveraineté de l'ukraine
comme la paix dans toute la région je
vous remercie jr président